después de un lunes con mucha de
certidumbres y cristal colombiano
defendió que está limpio del paje y que
las autoridades francesas no han
registrado ninguna sustancia no han
encontrado ninguna sustancia ilegal en
el medio de la investigación en torno a
su equipo nairo quintana explica que en
el operativo de la semana pasada al
término de la etapa del miércoles en
méribel la gendarmería allanó su
habitación e incautó unos productos que
en agro asegura son legales recordemos
que es la fiscalía de marsella la que
abrió esta investigación por sospecha de
dopaje en el arke samsic en el equipo de
negro y en ella no participa la agencia
antidopaje gala sino una rama de la
gendarmería como decimos lo que dicen
iron textualmente es ese día el
miércoles de la semana pasada las
autoridades ingresaron a mi habitación e
incautaron suplementos vitamínicos
perfectamente legales aunque quizá no
familiares para las autoridades
francesas continúan iron jamás he
utilizado sustancias dopantes y no se
encontró ninguna sustancia ilegal en la
investigación policial como parte de
esas pesquisas abiertas por la fiscalía
de marsella hay dos personas que
continúan en detención preventiva un
doctor
y un fisioterapeuta que completan ya más
de 24 horas en custodia